دكتور سعيد الحاج همم عن سوريا الامر يعني
بالنسبه للمتابعين اصبح معقدا للغايه فهم
المشهد بالنسبه لما يحدث في سوريا همم في
ظل العلاقات المعقده بين جميع همم الاطراف
الاقليميه همم ذات العلاقه بهذا الامر
مساء الخير مساء النور
القضيه السوريه انتقلت خلال سنوات الماضيه
بالمرحله الى اخرى هو واضح ان الان على
عتاب مرحله جديده هي جزء الحقيقه من مسار
معين في المنطقه يقلب صفحه ثورات العربيه
وما تلاها من همم كل التطورات الحقيقيه
خلال العقل الماضي واضح ان هناك مسار من
التهديئه والمصالحات وفتح الابواب المغلقه
التي استمرت لاكثر من 10 سنوات ربما حتى
الان تركيا جزء من هذا المشهد والدول
الاخرى الحقيقه جزء من هذا المشهد بعض
الدوافع هي متعلقه بطير هذه الصفحه كما
ذكرت بعضها متعلقه ايضا
بالتوجهات الاداره الامريكيه الجديده
واولوياتها ورغبتها في اثاره نوع من
الهدوء ربما بين مختلف الاطراف بعض
الدوافع التي هي متعلقه ببعض الدول
الداخليه الاقتصاد الى ذلك من هذه الزاويه
ثم على هامش الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
والعلاقات المتميزه مؤخرا او الدوره
المتميزه الذي لعبته تركيا في هذه الحرب
والتفاقات والاختراقات التي حققتها ازدياد
اهميه دوريها بالنسبه لدروس تحديدا وتوثق
العلاقات الروسيه التركيه كلها دفعت
الحقيقه بطريقه او باخرى الى فتح صفحه
جديده حتى على مستوى العلاقات التركيه
السوريه تقصد هنا تركيا والنظام السوري
التي لم تكن ربما منتظره خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه هنا طبعا هذه فعلا ربما